This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. On May 8, 1945, the Allied powers declared victory in Europe, putting an end to the Nazi regime. President Truman addressed the nation. General Eisenhower informs me that the forces of Germany have surrendered to the United Nations, much remains to be done. There was a lot to be done, rebuilding Europe, setting up a provisional government, and getting Germany to be less, well, not see-ish. Our producer, Sam Green's man, is just back from Deutschland. And to that end, there was one thing the Americans and the British and the French and the Russians
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。1945年5月8日，盟军宣布在欧洲取得胜利，终结了纳粹政权。杜鲁门总统向全国发表了讲话。艾森豪威尔将军通知我，德国军队已向联合国投降，但仍有许多工作要做。当时确实有很多事情要做，重建欧洲，建立临时政府，并让德国变得不那么……嗯，不那么“纳粹化”。我们的制片人萨姆·格林斯潘刚从德国回来。为了这个目的，美国人、英国人、法国人和俄国人有一件事
all wanted out of Germany. It was a book. Mein Kampf, or Mein Struggle, was Adolf Hitler's fictionalized autobiography. Then in it he outlines his political ideology and plans for Germany's future. It's a synthesis of his hatred for Jews and other groups and it was everywhere. The whole number of sold copies of Mein Kampf, only in Germany, at the end of World War II, was 12.45 million, and around one million copies in many, many different editions and translations in other languages. This is Sven Felix Kellerhoff, a journalist and author of a book about Mein Kampf. He says that according to one survey after the war, Every fifth German 105, half-ret Mein Kampf,
都想从德国得到。那是一本书。《我的奋斗》（Mein Kampf）是阿道夫·希特勒虚构的自传。他在书中概述了他的政治意识形态和对德国未来的计划。这是他对他仇恨犹太人及其他群体的综合体现，而且这本书无处不在。二战结束时，仅在德国，《我的奋斗》的销售总量就达到了1245万册，而在其他语言的许多不同版本和译本中，还有大约一百万册。这是斯文·菲利克斯·凯勒霍夫，一位记者，也是一本关于《我的奋斗》的书的作者。他说，根据战后的一项调查，每五个德国人中就有一个人读过《我的奋斗》。
Mein Kampf was given out to people when they joined the Nazi Party. And in some cities, the government would even give it as a wedding gift. It gives a copy to fresh married couples. as a wedding gift. As World War II drew to a close, a lot of Germans threw away or burned their copies of Mein Kampf. No one wanted to look like a Nazi to the Occupy in armies. Still, the Allies felt the need to ban the book. The Allies, especially the American military government, made in law in fall of 45, which banned Nazi Party itself, and also this law banned a minecomp. Now minecomp was only banned outright for a few years. After all, the third Reich had been infamous for censorship and banning books, and the
人们加入纳粹党时会被赠予《我的奋斗》。在一些城市，政府甚至把它当作结婚礼物。它会给新婚夫妇送上一本作为结婚礼物。随着二战接近尾声，许多德国人扔掉或烧毁了他们的《我的奋斗》。没有人想在占领军面前看起来像个纳粹。尽管如此，盟军还是觉得有必要禁止这本书。盟军，特别是美国军事政府，在45年秋天制定了一项法律，不仅禁止了纳粹党本身，还禁止了《我的奋斗》。现在，《我的奋斗》只被彻底禁止了几年。毕竟，第三帝国以审查制度和禁书而臭名昭著，而
last thing the new German Republic wanted was to look like Nazis. Hitler's intellectual property, including Mein Kampf, was ultimately given to the government of Bavaria, the state and southern Germany where Hitler rose to power. And the Bavarian government decided that as the copyright owners, they would not publish any new German editions of Mein Kampf, and they would seek to limit and control who had access to the book, that way they could make sure it was used only for scholarship and not in an attempt to revive fascism.
新成立的德意志共和国最不想做的就是看起来像纳粹。希特勒的知识产权，包括《我的奋斗》，最终被移交给了巴伐利亚政府，这是希特勒崛起并掌权的德国南部州。巴伐利亚政府决定，作为版权所有者，他们不会出版任何新的德文版《我的奋斗》，并将设法限制和控制谁能接触到这本书，这样他们就能确保它仅用于学术研究，而不是试图复兴法西斯主义。
And it just so happened that Germany had the perfect tool for the jobs. Something to help them deal with sensitive information that's neither censorship nor open access. The gift shrunk. Oh, this is the room? So we're in the gift shrunk? Gift shrunk. Gift meaning poison, shrunk meaning case or cupboard covered, or cabinet, a poison cabinet,
碰巧的是，德国拥有完成这项工作的完美工具。某种能帮助他们处理敏感信息，既不是审查也不是完全开放获取的东西。毒药柜（Giftschrank）。哦，这就是那个房间？所以我们在毒药柜里？毒药柜。Gift意为毒药，Schrank意为柜子或橱柜，即毒药柜，
or in this case, a room in the basement of the Bavarian State Library. The word gift shrunk can actually mean a few different things. In a pharmacy, it's a place for keeping controlled substances. But one of the oldest usages of this word, going back hundreds of years, is a gift shrunk of a library. A box or place to lock away materials deemed unfit for the public.
或者在这种情况下，是巴伐利亚州立图书馆地下室的一个房间。Giftschrank这个词实际上可以有几种不同的含义。在药房里，它是存放受管制物质的地方。但这个词最古老的用法之一，可以追溯到几百年前，是指图书馆的毒药柜。一个用来锁住被认为不适合公众阅读的材料的盒子或地方。
These materials were set aside not so much to protect them from people, but to protect people from them. Little biohazard zones for information. Over the course of centuries, these poison cabinets and German libraries have emptied and filled up, emptied again and filled up again. Their contents speaking volumes about what German society considers dangerous at any given moment. You can read the Giftschrank as a cultural history of morality of behavior. That's Stefan Kellner, a staff historian at the Bavarian State Library
这些材料被搁置一旁，与其说是为了保护它们免受人们的伤害，不如说是为了保护人们免受它们的伤害。这是信息的小型生物危害区。几个世纪以来，这些德国图书馆里的毒药柜不断清空又填满，清空又填满。它们的内容充分说明了德国社会在任何特定时刻认为什么是危险的。你可以把毒药柜解读为一部道德行为的文化史。这是斯特凡·凯尔纳，巴伐利亚州立图书馆的一位专职历史学家，
and author of a book about its Giftsrank. The name of my book is Der Giftsrank, erotic, sexual, Wissenschaft, Politik und Literatur, die weggesperrten Bücher der Bayerischen Staatsbültung. The Giftsrank, paradox, sexuality, politics and literature, hidden books of the Bavarian State Library. This story begins in this library shortly after the foundation in the 16th century. At this time, in the 1580s, Bavaria was a kingdom inside of the Holy Roman Empire, which didn't want the public reading works that they considered heretical. They put aside authors like Martin Luther and Galileo.
也是一本关于其毒药柜的书的作者。我的书名是《毒药柜：色情、性、科学、政治与文学，巴伐利亚州立图书馆被锁起来的书》。毒药柜，悖论，性，政治和文学，巴伐利亚州立图书馆的隐藏书籍。这个故事始于16世纪该图书馆成立后不久。当时，在1580年代，巴伐利亚是神圣罗马帝国境内的一个王国，它不希望公众阅读他们认为异端的作品。他们把马丁·路德和伽利略等作者的作品放在了一边。
Even some Catholic authors which were not okay for the Catholic Church. But while these anti-clarical writings may have been prohibited, the powers that be didn't just round up all the copies they could find and burn them, they thought it would be good to hold on to them. You have better arguments if you know what the other side thinks. At the order of the Duke of Bavaria, the library took all the forbidden literature and put it in a locked box and called it, the Dye Giff Trank, the Poison Cabinet. The box contained about 500 works opposed by the Catholic Church, which were kept around only as a means of reference for those working to oppose the people
甚至一些天主教会认为不妥的天主教作者的作品也被搁置。但虽然这些反教权著作可能被禁止，当权者并没有把他们能找到的所有副本都搜集起来烧掉，他们认为保留它们是有好处的。如果你知道对方在想什么，你就有更好的论据。在巴伐利亚公爵的命令下，图书馆把所有被禁的文学作品都放进了一个锁着的盒子里，并称之为“毒药柜”（Dye Giff Trank）。这个盒子里装了大约500部被天主教会反对的作品，这些作品被保留下来只是作为那些致力于反对
who opposed the Church. And they may not be used without permission of the Duke of Bavaria. But over time, the Catholic Church's grip over Europe got weaker. By the 1800s, the Gifts' ronks of German libraries were less concerned with protecting us from the Protestant writings of Martin Luther and more concerned with protecting us from sex. And this came to the fore when the King of the Varia acquired a private collection of books that had belonged to a guy named von Krenner. Franz von Krenner.
反对教会的人的参考资料。而且未经巴伐利亚公爵许可，不得使用这些资料。但随着时间的推移，天主教会对欧洲的控制力减弱了。到了1800年代，德国图书馆的毒药柜不再关心保护我们免受马丁·路德的新教著作的影响，而是更关心保护我们免受性的影响。当巴伐利亚国王获得了一批属于一个叫冯·克雷纳的人的私人藏书时，这一点变得尤为突出。弗朗茨·冯·克雷纳。
And the King wanted the library to house Franz von Krenner's collection, which was an assortment of books for adults. Books concerning love in all perspectives. Maki does sad, of course, and something about whipping and so on, which was whipping. People who like to be whipped and okay. Unwilling to throw these controversial books out and unwilling to make them readily available, librarians found a home for von Krenner's Arotica collection in the Giftsrunk, and they were very serious about keeping its contents secure. There were two keys, and only if they were to get it, they could open the Giftsrunk.
国王希望图书馆能收藏弗朗茨·冯·克雷纳的藏书，这是一批供成年人阅读的书籍。涉及各种视角下爱情的书籍。萨德侯爵的作品当然也在其中，还有关于鞭打之类的东西，也就是鞭打。喜欢被鞭打的人等等。图书馆员们不愿扔掉这些有争议的书籍，也不愿让它们轻易被获取，于是为冯·克雷纳的色情藏书在毒药柜里找到了一个家，而且他们非常认真地保护其内容的安全。有两把钥匙，只有当他们拿到钥匙时，才能打开毒药柜。
It's like a nuclear launch. Yes. And some people believe that the books inside the gift shrunk were so dangerous that they could literally make you sick. There was one librarian at the time who got crazy, Joseph Shira. And he got mentally ill. And after he was in the hospital, his friend went to his room, opened the cupboard, saw many of Krenner's books inside and said, I think that must have been the reason for his illness. Time passed, Germany fought and lost World War I, and from the rubble of that defeat grew
这就像核发射一样。是的。有些人甚至认为毒药柜里的书太危险了，以至于真的会让你生病。当时有一位图书管理员疯了，叫约瑟夫·希拉。他患上了精神疾病。在他住院后，他的朋友去了他的房间，打开了柜子，看到了里面许多克雷纳的书，说：“我想那一定是导致他生病的原因。”时间流逝，德国参加并输掉了第一次世界大战，从那场失败的废墟中成长起来的
a liberal counterculture. Dada is proclaimed that art was dead, expressionist films explored the darkness of the soul. Berliners passed late hours at Cabaret's, nudist's challenge traditional modesty. Berlin in 1920, it was sent off all forms of different life experiments. And at the center of all this was a physician named Magnus Hershfeld. And he founded an institute for all those people who had another sexual orientation than usual. Hershfeld also promoted acceptance of transgenderism, SDD prevention, contraception, and women's emancipation. He wrote that. The woman who needs to be liberated most is the woman in every man, and the man who needs to
是一种自由的反主流文化。达达主义宣称艺术已死，表现主义电影探索灵魂的黑暗。柏林人在歌舞表演中度过深夜，裸体主义者挑战传统的谦逊。1920年的柏林，是各种不同生活实验的中心。而这一切的核心是一位名叫马格努斯·赫希菲尔德的医生。他为所有那些性取向与众不同的人建立了一个研究所。赫希菲尔德还提倡接受跨性别主义、性病预防、避孕和妇女解放。他写道：“最需要解放的女人是每个男人心中的女人，而最需要
be liberated most is the man in every woman. But this liberal renaissance in Berlin would not last for long. As the Nazi party rose to power, Hirschfeldt's Institute for Sexual Sciences had become a target. Magnus Hirschfeldt was very famous at this time. He was gay. He was a Jew and he was leftist. In May of 1933, the German Student Union, a group affiliated with the Nazis, rated Magnus Hirschfeldt's Institute. They threw many of his books onto the street and burned them.
解放的男人是每个女人心中的男人。”但柏林的这场自由复兴并没有持续太久。随着纳粹党上台，赫希菲尔德的性科学研究所成为了目标。马格努斯·赫希菲尔德当时非常出名。他是同性恋。他是犹太人，也是左翼人士。1933年5月，隶属于纳粹的一个组织——德国学生会，突袭了马格努斯·赫希菲尔德的研究所。他们把他的许多书扔到街上并烧毁了。
This was four days before Nazis all across Germany started burning books by Jewish authors in public rallies. But even so, the new regime didn't get rid of everything. The very inside the library they said we have to keep them because we have to know what the enemy writes and to fight with him. So of course Magnus Hirschfeldt's books went into the gift shrunk. 12 years later, in 1945, the Nazis had lost the war, and now their own literature, including of course Mein Kampf, was thrown into the gift shrunk. The hope was to de-nautify Germany and build a new society. But Germany did not become a new society. It became two new societies. As the communist barrier between East and West Berlin
这发生在全德国纳粹开始在公开集会上焚烧犹太作者书籍的四天前。但即便如此，新政权并没有除掉一切。就在图书馆内部，他们说：“我们必须保留它们，因为我们必须知道敌人写了什么，才能与他战斗。”所以，马格努斯·赫希菲尔德的书当然进了毒药柜。12年后，即1945年，纳粹输掉了战争，现在他们自己的文学作品，当然包括《我的奋斗》，也被扔进了毒药柜。当时的希望是让德国去纳粹化并建立一个新社会。但德国并没有成为一个新社会。它变成了两个新社会。随着东西柏林之间共产主义屏障的
grows higher and stronger, the more determined grows the will of those in the East to escape. Along the border, East Berliners are forced to evacuate their homes, as the communist police moved to prevent their escape. The two Germany's would eventually each have their own government, their own culture, and of course, their own libraries. And the contents of each side's gift shrunk became a mirror for what was deemed dangerous in East and West.
越来越高、越来越强，东方那些想要逃离的人的意志就越坚定。在边境沿线，东柏林人被迫撤离家园，因为共产主义警察采取行动阻止他们逃跑。两个德国最终都将拥有各自的政府、各自的文化，当然，还有各自的图书馆。而每一方毒药柜里的内容，都成了被视为危险事物的镜子。
So the Nazi stuff, mine comps and the writings of Joseph Gebbels and Alfred Rosenberg, this could be found in gift shrunks in both West and East Germany. But while West Germany actually thinned out their gift shrunk over time, allowing more access to so-called pernicious information, in East Germany it was the opposite. East Germany was a dictatorship so there was like a very obvious and strict censorship, Western print material wasn't normally accessible. This is Elena Demko. While she was a student at university, she was looking to read some band Czech poetry. And with the help of an idealistic professor, she was able to get access to the room
所以纳粹的东西，《我的奋斗》以及约瑟夫·戈培尔和阿尔弗雷德·罗森堡的著作，在东西德的毒药柜里都能找到。但虽然西德随着时间的推移实际上精简了他们的毒药柜，允许更多地接触所谓的有害信息，但在东德情况恰恰相反。东德是一个独裁国家，所以有非常明显和严格的审查制度，西方的印刷材料通常是无法获取的。这是埃琳娜·登科。当她还是大学的一名学生时，她想读一些被禁的捷克诗歌。在一位理想主义教授的帮助下，她得以进入那个房间，
where the university library kept its band material. While the nickname was Gif Trom, library kept its band material. Well the nickname was Gif Traum, Poison Room. I would remember being really nervous and excited when I went there. It's a very big, representative 19th century building. So you have to go to the major staircase and you go up major stakers. And keep going up. Then there's smaller stakers and you go up's smaller staircase, we go up a smaller staircase. Until you reach a spiral staircase. You had to climb up a spiral staircase and all of a sudden
大学图书馆存放被禁材料的地方。绰号叫“毒药室”（Gif Traum）。我记得当我走进那里时，我真的很紧张和兴奋。那是一座非常宏伟的19世纪代表性建筑。所以你必须走到主楼梯，然后走上主楼梯。继续往上走。然后有较小的楼梯，你走上较小的楼梯，我们走上较小的楼梯。直到你到达一个螺旋楼梯。你必须爬上一个螺旋楼梯，突然之间，
he was standing front of a bunker door. It was made of iron and it had a big circular glass window, made of very thick glass and it had two huge bars which you had to push down at the same time in order to open the door. Past the bunker door was a dark room. A stern looking lady checked to see if your name was on a list. Then she got your book and let you go through another door. And then you went into the small reading room which which was a little glass dome, so it was a very light, a very pleasant, sunny place.
你站在一扇地堡门前。它是由铁制成的，有一个大的圆形玻璃窗，由非常厚的玻璃制成，还有两根巨大的横杆，你必须同时向下推才能打开门。穿过地堡门是一个黑暗的房间。一位神情严肃的女士检查你的名字是否在名单上。然后她拿到了你的书，让你穿过另一扇门。然后你进入了小阅览室，那是一个小玻璃穹顶，所以那是一个非常明亮、非常舒适、阳光充足的地方。
In East Germany, the Giftschrank had become a place you could visit. And in this library, at the University of Leipzig, the Giftschrank was actually a pretty lovely place to be. Was the best reading room in the house actually? You kinda see where people were reading? Of course I was. Elena had been hoping to meet other counter-culture types, who were also there to read politically conscious literature.
在东德，毒药柜已经变成了一个你可以参观的地方。而在莱比锡大学的这个图书馆里，毒药柜实际上是一个相当可爱的地方。这其实是馆内最好的阅览室。你还能看到人们在读什么？当然看到了。埃琳娜一直希望能遇到其他反主流文化的人，他们也是去那里阅读具有政治意识的文学作品的。
I was disappointed realizing that the other people were not reading politically relevant literature, and when I saw, you know, pretty students reading fashion literature I thought okay she chatted up her professor to get access to the Poison Room to read fashion magazines from the West. Within about a year of Elena visiting the Poison Room, the East German government had collapsed, the border was opened, and Germany was reunified. All across the former East Giff Schrank's shr, literature critical of the East German government, magazines that showed life in a capitalist society, they were taken out from
我感到很失望，意识到其他人并没有在阅读具有政治意义的文学作品，当我看到，你知道，漂亮的大学生在读时尚杂志时，我想，好吧，她和教授搭讪是为了进入毒药室阅读西方的时尚杂志。在埃琳娜访问毒药室大约一年后，东德政府垮台，边境开放，德国重新统一。在整个前东德的毒药柜里，批评东德政府的文学作品、展示资本主义社会生活的杂志，它们都被从
behind iron bunker doors and returned to normal circulation. Today the physical rooms and cabinets that once served as Giff Shrunkunks all across Germany are mostly empty. Their contents returned to the regular stacks, but not everything. Today, Mein Kampf is kept in what Stefan Kälner calls, a virtual gift shrunk. Meaning, there's no physical box or even a particular room, coordinating off the books from the user. Rather, the library relies on the infrastructure of their catalog and checkout system to create a series of checkpoints between the user and books that the library wants to keep an eye
铁地堡门后取出，恢复了正常流通。今天，曾经在德国各地作为毒药柜的物理房间和柜子大多是空的。它们的内容回到了常规书架上，但并非全部。今天，《我的奋斗》被保存在斯特凡·凯尔纳所说的“虚拟毒药柜”中。这意味着，没有物理盒子，甚至没有特定的房间将这些书与用户隔离开来。相反，图书馆依靠其目录和借阅系统的基础设施，在用户和图书馆想要密切关注的书籍之间建立了一系列检查点。
on. When you search for mine comp in the database, you can't just order it. You have to go see Susie. You know, my comp was pretty busy with the card. I can say English. A little bit. Susie Coolbeck was the librarian on the desk that day. And she said the first thing to do
当你在数据库中搜索《我的奋斗》时，你不能直接预订它。你必须去见苏西。你知道，我的奋斗在卡片上很忙。我可以讲英语。一点点。苏西·库尔贝克是那天在柜台的图书管理员。她说第一件事要做的是
First I want you to go to our chief to have the permission to land it and as long as you don't seem like a Nazi You can get a copy of mine comp no problem the process of accessing mine comp from the Bavarian State Library should feel pretty familiar to anyone Who's ever gotten material from an academic library. But if you're underage... Under 18, they need the signature from the parents. You dress like a god. If he has a Gothic costume, you know? Well, good luck getting through Suzy. Yeah. If someone says I want to get this book because I want to learn how to be a Nazi...
首先我需要你去我们的主管那里获得借阅许可，只要你看起来不像个纳粹，你就可以毫无问题地拿到一本《我的奋斗》。从巴伐利亚州立图书馆获取《我的奋斗》的过程，对于任何曾经从学术图书馆获取资料的人来说，应该感觉相当熟悉。但如果你未成年……18岁以下，他们需要家长的签名。你打扮得像个哥特人。如果他穿着哥特式服装，你知道吗？好吧，祝你能通过苏西那一关。是的。如果有人说我想得到这本书是因为我想学习如何成为一名纳粹……
No, no, that comes to no. Though if you do go through the trouble of checking out Mein Kampf, just don't go in expecting too much. I read it, it's boring. It's really funny. It's really... These days, of course, you don't need a library to read Mein Kampf in Germany. It's not hard to find a copy at an antiquarian bookstore and the text has been on the internet for at least a decade. Of course you can get Nazi literature in the internet and so on.
不，不，那是不可能的。虽然如果你确实费尽周折借到了《我的奋斗》，也别抱太大期望。我读过它，很无聊。这真的很有趣。这真的……当然，这些天在德国你不需要图书馆就能读到《我的奋斗》。在古籍书店找到一本并不难，而且这本书在互联网上至少已经存在了十年。当然，你可以在互联网上找到纳粹文学等等。
But even if the book is readily available on the internet, Stefan Kellner says the library still has a responsibility to try to control who reads their copies and for what purpose. Even if it's a bit anachronistic we have to be a little careful, not a little, we have to be careful with this part of our library. And now for the first time since Hitler was in power, new copies of Mein Kampf are on sale in Germany. On January 1, 2016, the copyright of Mein Kampf expired, which means this book is now in the public domain. The Institute for Contemporary History in Munich has just published a new critical edition of Mind Comp.
但即使这本书在互联网上很容易获得，斯特凡·凯尔纳说，图书馆仍然有责任尝试控制谁阅读他们的副本以及出于什么目的。即使这有点不合时宜，我们也必须小心一点，不是一点，我们必须小心对待我们图书馆的这一部分。现在，自希特勒掌权以来，新的《我的奋斗》副本首次在德国发售。2016年1月1日，《我的奋斗》的版权到期，这意味着这本书现在属于公共领域。慕尼黑当代历史研究所刚刚出版了《我的奋斗》的新批判性版本。
This edition is big, it's heavy, it's expensive, it's two volumes with 1500 pages of footnotes and commentary meant to disprove and contextualize all of Hitler's claims. notes in commentary, meant to disprove and contextualize all of Hitler's claims. There's no way you can mistake it as anything other than serious scholarship. It makes you work through layers and layers of critique in order to get to Hitler's writing. It's almost as if the publishers wrapped a gift shrunk around the new addition of mind comp so that the world would be inoculated from its poison. 99% Invisible Was Produced As Weeked by Sam Greenspan With Katie Mingle, Avery Trouffman, Delaney Hall, Kurt Colstead, Sharif Yusef, and me Roman
这个版本很大，很重，很贵，是两卷本，有1500页的脚注和评论，旨在反驳和语境化希特勒的所有主张。注释和评论，旨在反驳和语境化希特勒的所有主张。你不可能把它误认为是严肃学术研究之外的任何东西。它让你通过层层批判来理解希特勒的写作。这几乎就像出版商在《我的奋斗》的新版本周围包裹了一个毒药柜，这样世界就能免受其毒害。《99%隐形》由萨姆·格林斯潘制作，凯蒂·明格尔、艾弗里·特鲁夫曼、德莱尼·霍尔、库尔特·科尔斯特德、谢里夫·优素福和我罗曼
Mars. We have so many people to thank this week, many of whom have names I cannot pronounce, so I have Sam to do it. Thank you to Tobias Kolp, Wilhelm Hilpert, and Peter Schitzlein at the Bavarian State Library, Magnus Brechtkin and Simone Paul Mikoel at the Center for Contemporary History in Munich, Sarah Borey, Andre Kraber, Romy Kuneert, Luisa Beck, Pat McCD Miller, Ulf Schveckendijk, Daniel Wetzel, Ziegfried Locatus, Bernd Florat, Dagmar Huvistate, Michelle Krasowski, and Jeremy Ott.
马尔斯参与。本周我们要感谢很多人，其中许多人的名字我无法发音，所以我让萨姆来做。感谢巴伐利亚州立图书馆的托比亚斯·科尔普、威廉·希尔珀特和彼得·希茨莱因，慕尼黑当代历史研究所的马格努斯·布雷希特金和西蒙娜·保罗·米科尔，萨拉·博雷、安德烈·克拉伯、罗米·库内特、路易莎·贝克、帕特·麦克德·米勒、乌尔夫·施韦肯迪克、丹尼尔·韦策尔、齐格弗里德·洛卡图斯、伯恩德·弗洛拉特、达格玛·胡维斯塔特、米歇尔·克拉索夫斯基和杰里米·奥特。
Thank you one and all. Thanks also to Okakumi and Melodium for providing some of the music this week. We'll have a full list on the website. We are a production of 99% Invisible Ink, a project of KL-91.7 in San Francisco, and produced under the offices of Arxine, an architecture in interiors for imbeutable downtown, Oakland, California. You can find this show and join the fine community of people who would like this show on Facebook. I love seeing all the 99pi coins showing up on Twitter and Instagram, but if you want to explore the 99% Invisible activity that shapes the design of our world, I recommend
感谢大家。也感谢Okakumi和Melodium为本周提供了一些音乐。我们将在网站上提供完整列表。我们是《99%隐形》公司的作品，是旧金山KL-91.7的一个项目，并在加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心Arxine建筑与室内设计公司的办公室下制作。你可以在Facebook上找到这个节目并加入喜欢这个节目的优秀社区。我喜欢看到所有99pi硬币出现在Twitter和Instagram上，但如果你想探索塑造我们世界设计的《99%隐形》活动，我建议
you spend some time with 99PI. dot org. Thanks. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你花点时间访问99PI.org。谢谢。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。